one of the great stories in the NBA is
Duncan Robinson born in Maine grew up in
New Hampshire played Division three
basketball then went to Michigan and all
of a sudden you realize he's one of the
best shooters in the NBA and all he does
is shoot threes so I immediately loved
Duncan Robinson who joins us on the
program the Miami Heat forward Duncan
how are you I'm doing well
appreciate you okay a couple of things
Andre Iguodala who was with Golden State
had the ultimate compliment I think for
you when well not the ultimate because
he thought I think you were the ball boy
when he first got to Miami Heat is that
right yeah I don't know if that's
actually a legitimate quote I think that
was you know kind of somewhat made-up oh
yeah a little bit Andre obviously you
know I'm now pretty close and he's been
a great mentor to me ever since he's
been at Miami but I'm not in that
category yet in terms of you know his
other teammates okay but he did say that
you were the best shooter he's seen is
that right that's the quote now are you
saying that that's not true either
I don't know if that's entirely true I
don't think he said that that verbatim
you know he's definitely given me a lot
of confidence but like I said I don't
think he thinks or or personally I think
I'm in that category just yet well why
the hell am I having you on if you
weren't mistaken for a ball boy and
being called the best shooter that Andre
Iguodala has has ever seen I'm not sure
it could be true that I'm assuming but I
you know I kind of came on I guess a
little bit I'm not sure okay but you go
division three then you go to Michigan
and you end up with the heat and I
started looking at the numbers and I go
this guy doesn't shoot any twos it's
basically three or nothing how did you
become this great 3-point shooter and I
do mean great um
just a lot of repetitions you know I
feel like I've always kind of had an
ability to shoot the ball I've
definitely improved here in the last you
know three to four years I think
Michigan helped me a lot
my player development and then never
since I've been with Miami they really
hardwired into my brain to really just
just shoot threes i'ma do what I do well
and you know for me that's that's doing
my job and being aggressive what was
your welcome to the NBA moment good or
bad I would probably say this year we
were playing the Lakers oh right this
this was early on in the year before I
had a little bit of a reputation and
they put LeBron on me basically just had
him sit in the paint you know see such a
good help side defender that was
probably just that's a real moment of
being on the floor but also you know
kind of being but the fact that you sort
of weren't guarded by him either but
when did it change when did you start
getting respect from defense's just kind
of gradually over time as a year went on
my rule kind of started to shift at
first I was coming off the bench and
just kind of being a spark and a floor
spacer as the year went on I got put in
more and more action and was asked to do
a little bit more so it was just gradual
I wouldn't necessarily cite one in
particular moment where everything kind
of changed what about the three-point
shooting contest yeah I mean that was in
many ways I mean I kind of laid an egg I
wish I could could have it back in terms
of my performance that weekend but hell
nervous were you I was pretty it's just
such an unnatural setting you know
you're you're sitting there waiting for
the the contest to come and you get him
out like a minute to warm up and then
all of a sudden you're just kind of
thrown into the fire so that was
definitely a little bit of a way for me
to gain a little bit more notoriety in
that you know I was kind of getting some
recognition after that did you talk to
any of those guys do you talk to like
can you walk over to Steph Curry prior
to a game and just like great shooter to
great shooter have a conversation or
klay Thompson I haven't I haven't had
that moment with either those guys
obviously they missed a lot of this year
that's right so I haven't had that
moment with either those guys I
we'll say to him pretty surreal I've
been able to kind of develop
relationships with guys like JJ reddick
and cop over guys who I've always really
looked up to who've done my job at the
highest of levels so it's been pretty
cool to just kind of learn from them and
pick their brains on different things
the heat worked out in Miami yesterday
you leave for Orlando here coming up in
a few days hell nervous are you oh it's
a combination of kind of anxious and
excited you know I think first and
foremost I think we're all excited to
get back to playing obviously there's a
lot of uncertainty that's coming with
the being in this bubble it's
unprecedented in a lot of ways but you
know we're also excited about just
getting back out and competing yeah we
gonna be in the bubble yeah I mean it's
it's a totally different scenario than
obviously anyone's ever faced I think
there's there's gonna be some bumps in
the road in terms of how it all comes
together but I think what's most
important is that between the league and
the teams there's definitely that in
front in that everybody wants to play
yeah but you're how many times you've
been tested we could test it every other
day since June 21st so I probably say
like five or something like that what's
that process like it's it's uh I've
gotten used to it
it's gotten more and more comfortable at
first it was definitely uncomfortable a
little invasive for sure but at this
point it's basically become habit
considering I do it every other day I
saw where the Greek freak said whoever
wins this championship
you deserve an asterisk because you will
have pulled off maybe the greatest
championship given everything that's at
stake everything you got to go through
if we even get to an NBA Finals what do
you think of that quote by the Greek
freak I think there's definitely some
truth to it
you know one thing we've really been
talking about as a team is that this
will definitely be a test of competitive
will and then also just mental toughness
so I think whatever team can can pull
through in that regard I will definitely
have a competitive advantage I know
you're doing a sweepstakes yes Duncan
Robinson is running a sweepstakes
contest I think you're involved with the
United Way so would you like to let the
audience no yeah absolutely I'm doing an
event with United Way and engage
basically it's a you know just a way to
first of all give back to the community
of Miami and everything that's going on
between you know the recent social
justice push and also you know Cove it
obviously as well obviously a hundred
percent of the proceeds are going
towards the cause and the the grand
prize is basically just like a VIP game
that with me you'll be my guest
all the way through from previous to
supposed to him as well and there's a
bunch of other prizes as well so like I
said one hundred percent of the proceeds
are going towards the cause and you know
obviously in times like this it requires
people to give up both their their time
and their money I'm not trying to do
both so I think this is a way for me to
do that give the website to people if
they want more information on this I
even go to let's engage his is the
platform that I'm using it through and
like you mentioned it's the Duncan
Robinson sweepstakes
are you a Patriots fan I did grow up a
Patriots fan yes but you didn't answer
the question
are you okay I will say it gets tough as
you get older your loyalty kind of
shifts you know now I feel like I'm very
much a citizen of the city of Miami so I
was excited to see if they drafted to up
I'm excited for the future but you know
in my in my heart I will also always be
a Patriots fan as well
have you gone to games in Miami I I have
I went to a game last year when they
played the Patriots at home which
honestly that it felt more like a fox
game in Foxborough Miami
have you gone to games in Foxborough I
went to one growing up I went to one so
I I grew up north of Boston Foxborough
South so getting through the city and
getting down there is always a challenge
of traffic Duncan good luck it's been a
great it's a success story and you don't
find too many guys who went to Williams
College who end up in the NBA and we
wish it we wish you well there in
Orlando I will thank you very much I
appreciate you all right let's Duncan
Robinson 26 years of age and Fritzi did
some great research there and Duncan
Duncan Duncan you got to stay with that
story though that
you know they thought you were the ball
boy and that andre iguodala said you're
the greatest shooter he's ever been
around okay you got to stay with that
story okay yes yes I gotta get I gotta
get with your PR people Thank You Duncan